はじめ「いきます。」
よっち「はい」
はじめ「こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと！」
よっち「こんにちは！よっちです！」
はじめ「おまえ！」　よっち「うわあ！」
はじめ「はじめしゃちょーVSよっち、クイズ対決！！」
二人）イェーイ！！　　　（効果音）　　　（二人）うおうおうおうおうお
はじめ「はい、というわけで今回はよっちと僕でクイズ対決していこうと思います。」　　　　　　　　　　　　よっち「イェーイ！」
はじめ「イェイ？」　よっち「イェイ」
よっち「おうっ！、うん♡」
はじめ「普通のクイズ対決やってこうと思うんですけど、も、ルールが何個かありまして、
まず一つ目
よっち「ハイテンション？」
はじめ「一回練習してみよっか」
ふたり「:@+"$%#()$(-~ﾋﾟﾖﾋﾟﾖ~~！！」
はじめ「ハズレの方に、仕掛けがあるみたいです」
はじめ「正解不正解もリアクションでわかるんでー
わかりやすいと思うので」
よっち「でもテンションは継続って感じ・・・？」
はじめ「そうそうそう」
はじめ「ｴｲﾔ〜〜〜〜〜〜！！」
はじめ「早速やっていきましょう！」
はじめ「では、第一問と言われた瞬間から、もう始まりますから」　よっち「あぁ、なるほど」
はじめ「じゃあ、宜しくお願いします」よっち「お願いします」　協力者「はい」
はじめ&よっちがここから超ハイテンションになります
よっち「何も聞こえない！！」
はじめ「はい！」　よっち「ああ！」
はじめ「あぁやったよ！」
よっち「まるだ、ヤターーーー！」
よっち「あ゛ぁ゛ごめぇん！」
はじめ「いただきます」
はじめ「カラァッ！？」
はじめ「みずぅっ」
テンション普通に戻って　よっち「きついっすよねぇ」
はじめ「はいというわけで」
はじめ「ェエッヘイ」
協力者「それでは第２問です」　またハイテンションに戻ります」
よっち「はいっ！」　協力者「はい、よっちさん」　はじめ「ありゃぁ」
よっち「まるどこですか？」
よっち「あっ、これか、やった、ありがと:@+"$%」
はじめ「オープン！！」
はじめ「い〜ただきます！」
はじめ「うまいっ！×３」
よっち「あ゛ぁ゛ぁ゛！！！
よっち「む゛ぁ゛ぁ゛ぁ゛！！」「はぁ゛ぁ゛ぁ゛っはーっははぁ゛
みんなは、真似しちゃダメだぞっ^_−☆
普通のテンションに戻ります
はじめ「いやめっちゃ美味しいカレーで、よかったぁ」
はじめ「では、3問目行きましょう！」よっち「行きましょう」
協力者「では、第3問です。」
ここからハイテンションです
はじめ「はいっ！」
はじめ「頭悪いんじゃねぇのかぁぁっ！！」　よっち「フワァァツ！！」
よっち「ぱっかーん、ワァァッ！」
はじめ&よっち「いただきます」
はじめ「あ゛っあ゛あ゛っあ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛、後からくるやつだこれ！:@+"$%#()$
ここから普通のテンションです
はじめ「はい、というわけで、次が最終バトルでございます」
はじめ「さっき僕が喰らったのがデスソースだったので
最後はデスソースより上のやつが来るってことだから」
はじめ「あるよ」
協力者「それでは第4問です」
ここからまたハイテンションです
はじめ「よく命かかってんのにテンションあげられるなwww」　よっち「いやいやいやwww」
よっち「へっ？優勝校が出ている？」
協力者「はい、よっちさん」
よっち「出ていません、バツっ！！！」　協力者「どうぞぉっ！」
よっち「アァァァァ」　はじめ「せぇのっ！』
よっち「フワァァッ、あ゛あ゛あ゛（咳き込む）えっ、うそぉっ、フォォッフォッフォォッ！」
よっち「えっ、どうしたんですか、違うんですか？
はじめ「ハハハハハ！」
はじめ「はい、というわけで、黒猫のウィズにはこういうクイズがたくさん入っております』
はじめ「ただいま、CMもやっているみたいですよぉっ！」
はじめ「バイバァイッ！」　よっち「イェイッ！バイバイッ！ドワァッ！」
エンディングテーマ〜♪
thank you Hajime!!!